Just wanted to begin today by
pointing out a couple of
articles
from today's Boston Globe.
There's an article that's on
the financial
pages about investors
reconsidering gene therapy,
and startups funded as
technology evolves.
A lot of you have heard the
words gene therapy.
A lot of you,
at the end of that bacterial
genetics lecture,
said you
weren't quite sure what
complementation was.
But, gene therapy is basically
complementation put to work.
The
idea is if you got a broken
gene, and you can put in a good
copy, then
you'll take the cell back to
being normal,
which is exactly what we're
doing in those phage crosses
where we had two phage,
one with the
mutant copy of the gene,
and one with the wild type copy
of the gene.
And they're saying here that
there's a renewed interest.
Now, the basic strategy in
these things is to take usually
a
retrovirus, the same kind of
idea that we heard about with
the HIV-1
virus that will make a DNA
copy, and then the copy gets
inserted
somewhere in the chromosome.
So, the good thing is it puts
in a new
copy in a chromosome.
The bad thing is you got a
piece of DNA being
stuck somewhere in the
chromosome.
And there are places where it
can go
where it doesn't matter,
and there are other places
where it
really does matter.
So, it's been a very tricky
business
with gene therapy.
Part of the thrust here is
they're thinking that
maybe they need to pick targets
were the person's going to die
anyway so
that if there is a risk of
getting cancer or something,
it's outweighed
by the possible thing.
That's sort of the thrust.
You can see the
article; it's in today's paper.
It's very timely for what we
are
talking about now.
And then on Friday I'm going to
start talking about recombinant
DNA strategies and stuff.
But there's
another article in today's
paper.
This is one of those things
that I
told you about where an article
is published in the,
in this case,
online in the journal Nature.
They have an embargo on a press
thing
until Thursday or so,
and then the article is on,
the hot papers that
have just come out show up in
the newspapers,
usually either on Friday
or Monday.
And this is yet another system
that they describe as making
a molecular repair kit that
corrects mutations in the cells'
DNA.
So far, this has only been done
in cells.
But it's working well
enough, and the article is
saying this approach could
become a serious
competitor to conventional gene
therapy.
In here, you have sort of
a layman's account of this kind
of complementation by gene
therapy.
We're talking about gene
therapy in that field which
attempts to force
feed healthy genes into cells
hobbled by defective ones has
been
plagued by failure,
and recently was found to cause
leukemia
in some patients.
That's probably because of the
insertion events associated
with these viruses.
This new system
rewrites the small stretch of
misspelled genetic code.
That's
typically the reason the gene
has gone bad.
So it's a different kind
of strategy.
This is the first report I've
heard of that.
Some of
the stuff we're talking about
is sort of inescapable because
you're
going to see it in the paper.
Here, they're telling you the
sort
of thing I was just saying.
The viruses inject their
payloads at
random within the cell's mass
of DNA sometimes disrupting
normal
genes.
Even when genes land in good
locations, the molecular
machinery
that regulates their activity
is also often thrown off,
leaving the
healthy genes operating at a
level too low to be helpful or
functioning
in the wrong parts of the body.
It must begin to sound
familiar.
You
stick a random piece of DNA
somewhere, you can disrupt the
regulation in the gene as well
as just landing in the open
reading frame.
So there's a problem with gene
therapy.
Now, they'd like to make you
think that this is going to be
the promise to everything,
but as always it's more
complicated.
And
so, I just picked up the last
paragraph of this article.
Other
scientists said the approach
looked promising,
but predicted it would
end up struggling with this
problem of its own,
James M.
Wilson, a gene
therapy researcher at the
University of Pennsylvania.
Now, there's
somebody who's in a position to
criticize, but also has a vested
interest himself in the
alternative therapy,
noted that the first step
of the new process causes for
zinc fingers.
It's a kind of protein that's
involved in this,
to make a fresh
break in DNA to accommodate the
insertion of the corrected
sequence.
It's the same kind of break
with radiation that can lead to
cancer.
And we're going to talk today
about, you'll see where
double-stranded
breaks and whatnot can be a
real problem in terms of the
integrity of
the DNA and genome stability,
which is maintaining gene
stability so
important in avoiding cancer.
You guys are a tough crowd.
Comments ranged from,
this was the best lecture that
I'd given to ones
that were absolutely the other
end of the spectrum.
You're a very hard
group.
I truly am going to take,
I don't have time really to sit
back
and redo all my lectures,
but I've a huge amount of
input, and I'm going
to go back over all this input
I'm getting, and take it very
seriously
in terms of how I go about
things next year.
I can see a number of changes
I'm going to make.
Whoever sent me the
e-mail that talked about the
Dock Street Bohemian Pilsner
brewed in
Utica, NY, this classic golden
Pilsner, pungent,
perfumy taste and
so on, it was a moment of
lightness, but if I got too many
things like
that it's not going to help me
in trying to figure out how to
do.
For the person who asked about
how to avoid accidental
pollination,
when they're going to do that,
they actually take the stamens
off the
flowers so you don't get
accidental self fertilization.
You actually go
out and make ones that are just
male or just female flowers.
You can do
that rather easily.
OK, so what we got into last
time, or what I told
you last time,
and I promise you that there's
another Mendel
lecture coming.
For those of you who thought
this
was a little slow,
you may find the next one is
all too fast.
But
anyway, that will be how it
goes.
Mendel had carried out this
fundamental series of
experiments.
And I did linger over it
because I
think it's so simple you can
actually see the scientific
process
in action, and it also isn't
complicated by any techniques
that
we can't see.
And it was a tremendously
important insight that
genetic information came in
units.
But as I told you,
it wasn't
accepted because for most of
the world at the time,
it was a
statistical argument.
There weren't any entities that
were two of inside
a cell, and all that sort of
thing.
So, it didn't take over
scientific
thinking.
It wasn't until about 1900 when
several other geneticists
did finally find systems that
duplicated Mendel's results,
and
therefore showed that these
were general inferences,
something that
Mendel himself,
as I told you,
by choosing weeds and bees as
follow-up
systems hadn't been able to do.
These other geneticists showed
them
in other systems.
But the other thing that made
the difference at
the time, was by this point
cytologists, who were looking at
cells under microscopes,
had found entities whose
behavior seemed to
match those of these particles
of information that Mendel had
postulated to explain these
patterns of inheritance that he
was seeing.
These particles,
because they were called
chromosomes, which literally
means colored things,
the reason they were colored
was not because
they were inherently colored,
but because cytologists were
staining
the cells with a variety of
things.
And that was what allowed them
to
visualize these.
And so, by staring into
microscopes,
right around this time,
around the turn of the century,
1900s or so,
cytologists had come up with
three key observations.
One was that
chromosomes came in matched
pairs.
So, let's say in this cell,
there were too long and too
short.
So
that's a chromosome.
And it corresponds,
we now know,
to a
double-stranded DNA molecule
that's been all condensed up.
And there are two copies of
each chromosome in this thing.
So: two
long, two short,
one came from mom,
one came from dad.
And for
bookkeeping purposes,
I'm going to color them so that
from one parent
is unshaded,
and the other one is shaded.
Most of you know in human
cells we have 23 pairs of
chromosomes.
This is a now fancier method of
visualizing chromosomes called
painting chromosomes where you
take little stretches of DNA
that
are unique to particular
sequences, attach dyes,
and then use them to
stain the cells,
and so they will color only
particular chromosomes.
And we have 22 pairs of
identical chromosomes,
and then the sex
chromosomes here,
X and Y, this would be a male,
or two X's
if we were .
We'll return to those in the
next
lecture.
Kim Nasmyth,
who spent his life working on
how these
chromosomes segregate gave a
talk a year ago.
He's in London at a
hospital in London.
And then he brought in the next
slide.
There
was an artist who spent several
months visiting with him,
trying to
find ways to represent in art
some of what she saw going on.
And I
thought you might enjoy seeing
this, the slide.
This is the human
complement of chromosomes,
represented in stripy socks
that
various staff members from the
hospital brought in for
her to do this.
So, a little touch of scientist
humor which some of you may
think is pretty nerdy,
but anyway there it
was for what it's worth.
He showed that in our
departmental
colloquium.
OK, the second thing,
then, that the cytologists
noted by staring at this was
during ordinary cell division,
which gives
two identical daughters the
numbers of chromosomes per cell
is preserved.
And this ordinary cell division
is given a special name of
mitosis.
So
if we take this cell,
the first thing that happens,
then, is the
chromosomes are duplicated.
We've talked a lot about DNA
synthesis at the molecular
level.
This is looking at it.
Excuse me,
and so, there are now two DNA
molecules, that each one of
these
new DNA molecules is given a
special name.
This is called a chromatid.
So there was one DNA molecule
here.
It's now duplicated,
but you'll notice these are
still joined
together.
The point at which they are
joined together is known as the
centromere.
And then, after this,
after the DNA's been copied,
these
things are lined up at the
center of the cell and then they
are pulled
apart to give two daughter
cells that are just like what
you started with.
This part, so this is 2N,
if N is
the number of kinds of
chromosomes.
And then there's two each.
This is
2N.
At this point,
the DNA contents of the cell is
4N.
This is 2N.
We're back to where we started.
This part was
invisible to the cytologists,
at least in the sense the
chromosomes
at this point are extended.
And so, they weren't able to
visualize them
by looking through the
microscope.
But as it came time for cell
division, then the chromosomes
condensed up very tightly.
This is probably to avoid
tangles.
And you need to pull them apart
into
the two daughter cells.
And then the part that you
could see, this
was known as mitosis,
this process by which the
chromosomes are pulled
apart.
So, mitosis is a mechanism for
nuclear division that results in
two daughters with identical
genetic information.
When you contrast this to
meiosis,
which I'll show you in just a
minute, this has been studied
for
years in a kind of observation
way.
I showed you at some point.
This is
an animal cell where the
chromosomes line up,
and then they pull apart.
I think I showed you,
and you can see the cells
divide once they've
done that.
I'm going to show you this next
thing, which everything
happens more slow motion.
This is a picture of the blood
lily, so it's a
plant.
Again, the choice of model
system is often,
if it has a feature
that is good for a particular
thing.
This happens,
very easy to visualize in these
lily cells.
Now here, the
cells have duplicated their
chromosomes, and the daughter
chromosomes are held together.
They're glued together,
so you can
tell in this thing that they've
been glued.
Now, in order to separate
the first thing they have to do
is line up at the equator of the
cell.
And then it pulls apart and you
can see that each daughter cell
gets one
of the duplicated chromosomes.
OK, so that's mitosis.
It generates
two copies of what you started
with.
The other observation that the
cytologists made was that cell
divisions that produce sex cells
work by a different system.
So, the third thing,
And, I'm going to give you the
scientific word now for sex
cells.
So, they're usually called
gametes.
General term,
so that would be sperm and egg,
or pollen would
be a kind of gamete.
In this process,
the number of
chromosomes is halved.
And this special type of cell
division is
known as meiosis.
It's very important,
because if we didn't have
meiosis we wouldn't have any
progeny.
We need to be able to cut the
number of chromosomes we have
per cell in
half, so as Mendel inferred,
then when each parent made a
contribution
you'd be back up to the right
number of cells.
Now, so this process
begins again by duplication of
the DNA.
So this would be 2N.
Now we go to,
as before, with one interesting
difference here.
So we are at 4N in the cell. But
you notice that I've drawn
these duplicated chromosomes
with
chromatids overlapping.
This point of,
I didn't do this too well.
The
point of connection:
where the two chromosomes
overlap is known as
the chiasma.
It's a point of actual physical
interaction between
the chromosomes.
And what it allows the cell to
do is
to have the two homologous
chromosomes, in this case the
two
long ones, find each other,
and actually physically
interact.
That's a critical event for the
next step that I'm going to show
you.
It's also a point,
which you'll see in the next
lecture, there is
additional genetic diversity
introduced into the system.
So, at this point,
what's happened is that the DNA
has doubled, at this
point, looks sort of like
mitosis except for the fact that
the
duplicated chromatids have
overlapped.
There's a least one of
these for every pair of
duplicated chromosomes.
So what happens in the
next phase, which is known as
meiosis I is that the pairs of
duplicated chromosomes are
separated.
So, we get two cells.
We might get,
say, the unshaded of this one
and
the shaded of the little guys.
And the other one then is
shaded with a
long one and unshaded with this
one.
This is 2N, and this is 2N.
But if
you'll take a look at what's
happening over here,
you will see
that we don't have the same
thing going on.
In that case,
we were producing identical
copies of the starting
cell.
In this case,
we've got something different
now because
we've separated both copies of,
let's say, the chromosome from
dad
from both copies of the
chromosome that originated with
mom, and the
other way over here.
These, then,
undergo a second round that's
known as meiosis II,
which resembles now mitosis in
the
sense that the duplicated
chromatids are now pulled apart
into daughter
cells so that this one will
generate one long,
unshaded one,
one short,
and there will be two of those.
In the cell,
it will generate a shaded
long and unshaded like that.
So now, there are four of
these.
And you'll notice that there is
now an N.
So, we halved the number of
chromosomes during meiosis via
a process by two rounds of
division.
The other thing you can think
of is you can begin to see,
at least, when
the evolution of sex was such a
powerful force in driving
evolution
by introducing so much
variation, because each of us
has a copy of
each of our 22 chromosomes
where we have homologous pairs,
one from mom,
one from dad.
That every time we make a sex
cell,
a sperm or an egg,
what happens is for chromosome
1, you can either get
a copy from mom or the copy
from dad.
And then the next one:
copy
from mom, copy from dad,
and so on.
You can see the variation is
possible just from that part of
the process alone.
And there's going to
be more variation that comes
about from events that happen
where this
chiasma is as I'll show you.
So, meiosis then,
as I said, is a
mechanism for nuclear division
that produces four daughter
cells with
half the genetic info of the
original.
So, how did I write that?
And in this case,
the daughters are not
identical.
Does somebody have a
question?
Yeah?
Oh, this part of the process,
the
cytologists broke this down
when they were observing.
So, it was a
part they couldn't see.
When they started to be able to
see it, they
first saw this one division,
and then the second division.
They
called the first round of
division of meiosis I,
and the
second meiosis 2.
So it was just a name given to
the
process.
Yeah?
Oh, sorry, excuse me,
I see the problem.
OK, it goes
this way.
This period of time is called
meiosis I.
That part of the
process is called meiosis I,
meiosis II, sorry.
Yeah, I mean what I wrote down
as arbitrary.
You could've had 2 from
mom, and 2 from dad.
And in fact,
I guess if we have 22 pairs we
could
eventually have a sperm or egg
that had all of the copies from
mom, and
all of the copies from dad.
You could calculate the
statistical
chances of that happening,
but what you'll discover as
we'll find next
time, is that even if you did
that the chromosomes would no
longer be
identical to what you got from
mom or dad, because there's a
little bit
of genetic recombination going
on during that process.
I'll also show
in a minute that you can get
errors in this process,
and that
these are important.
So, what happens then is that
fertilization,
what the cytologists can see
happened was that the number
of chromosomes have been
halved.
So, you had N plus N giving you
2N
where this might be,
for example,
the egg, and this might be the
sperm, since gametes have half
the number of genetic content
when they
fuse, then you go back to the
original number.
And this gave rise to what was
known as the chromosomal theory
of
inheritance.
Even though cytologists didn't
know what these
colored things were,
they seemed to have the
properties that you would
expect the carriers of the
genetic information to have.
Be duplicated before a cell was
going to divide and then they
seemed
to be very precisely segregated
so that each daughter cell got
one
copy.
And it made sense,
then, in terms of the formation
of sex cells
you'd have, and then it would
all come back up.
So, the cytologists
proposed this chromosomal
theory of inheritance.
Chromosomes were the
carriers that carried the
genetic information.
And you can see now that
Mendel's work was rediscovered,
which is more
or less what happens around
1900, how beautifully it mapped
on top of
this because the genetic
information came in particles.
You'd think,
oh,
well those particles are
sitting on those chromosomes.
They get
duplicated.
They get separated.
They get divided in half.
Their
number gets divided in half
when you make sex cells.
So, I want to at least point
out, let me go onto this next
thing here.
Here was one other picture I'd
shown you.
This was a cancer cell
dividing again.
We see the same process at
work.
And that just
reminds you,
when I was talking about that
kind of process,
trying
to remind you that one cell
gives rise to two cells,
and one DNA
molecule gives rise to two DNA
molecules.
But these phenomena are related
even though one talks about them
in different parts of the
courses, and if you've got more
than one DNA
molecule per cell,
then each one's a chromosome.
And then you have to
take care of segregating those
as well.
But a point that I'd made is
that up until this part to the
right could be a yeast or an E.
coli, but
if it's going to be someone,
something more complicated
that's
got different kinds of cells
like us, then we have these
ultimately,
an adult human with 10^14 cell.
So, this process has happened
over,
and over, and over again.
And it has to be really very
accurate.
And, there was remarkable
advances have been made in
understanding this
process over the last few
years.
And a lot of this was due to
the
work of Lee Hartwell,
who carried out experiments,
I guess, that offered some key
insights into the basis of the
whole
cell cycle, of which this is
just part.
So they said,
here we can't
really see all of this stuff in
the microscope.
What cytologists were
able to observe was that after
the chromosomes had duplicated,
then
they condensed up.
They became visible,
and they could see that
part of the system.
So, a great body of knowledge
has
been learned over the past few
years.
Lee Hartwell,
who was a
postdoc at MIT with Boris
Magasanik a number of years ago,
was one of
the key people who led to this
round of insights.
And what we now know,
the cell cycle can be basically
divided into four parts.
So a newly born cell,
if you will,
undergoes what's known as phase
of
the cell cycle that's known as
the G1 phase.
And you could think of
this as, amongst other things,
sort of preparation for
duplicating the
cell's DNA.
And then, there's a phase known
as the S-phase,
which is
when DNA synthesis takes place.
That now gives the cell an
information content of 4N.
There was then another phase
known as G2,
which you could think of as
preparation for pulling the
chromosomes apart,
and for the cell dividing.
And that's
known as mitosis.
And so, this is quite
remarkable.
It's quite fundamental.
It's a very elegant and very
complex system of
controls.
And what Lee learned is that
there is an elaborate system of
what we now know as checkpoints
in the cell cycle.
And the idea is
pretty much the same sort of
thing that you might do if you
were an
engineer and you were setting
up a quality control process
that
involved a series of stages.
And what a checkpoint does is
it
basically demands successful
completion of a prior phase
before
the system is permitted to move
to the next stage.
And you can sort of
see the problem here,
that if you are trying to,
say you're copying
your chromosome,
your DNA, and you only got part
way through.
And
then you proceeded to the part
where you pulled the chromosomes
apart.
There would be all kinds of
chaos inside of the cells
because you
would be breaking chromosomes.
You wouldn't be getting
identical
information.
And there are three major
checkpoints.
There is a
checkpoint at the G1/S
boundary.
There is actually more than
one.
But there's an intra-S phase
checkpoint, and then there's
another
one at the G2/M boundary as
well.
And the way that Lee found this
out,
I wanted to just take you back
because remember when I was
talking,
well, first we talked about how
would you get a mutant affecting
an
essential cell,
a gene whose function is
essential for the cell.
We said you'd have to be
conditional in some kind of way,
because the organism would be
dead, and couldn't use genetics
to study
it.
So, when I introduced you to
those phage, and we wanted to
study
critical functions needed for
phage growth,
we needed a conditional
mutant.
Remember, we did look for
temperature sensitive mutants.
So that's what Lee Hartwell
started to do with yeast in 1970
approximately.
He just looked for mutations
that were temperature
sensitive lethals in yeast.
Now, yeast can be diploid,
but they
also can be haploid,
which is just one copy of
genetic information.
So
just like a bacterium,
haploid yeast,
if you get a mutation
affecting a gene,
then you see its phenotype
right away because there
isn't a complication of the
second chromosome.
And Lee got the Nobel
Prize for his work,
just, I forget,
three years ago or a short time
ago
anyway.
And so, this was the process he
was studying.
I showed you this movie.
In this case,
this is budding yeast,
and you
can see why it's called budding
yeast is that rather than the
still
growing and segregating down
the middle, the daughter cells
grow as
little buds coming off the
side.
The DNA is still going to be
duplicated as we got,
and then segregated into the
daughter.
So
that part of the process is
there, but there's yeast growing
sped up a
bit so you can see it.
So, what Lee found was that
when he
looked at his TS mutants,
he found that they tended to
arrest at
characteristic stages,
and he was able,
then, to figure out that there
must be some sort of checkpoint
system that is something went
wrong
during one of the stages,
then the cells with all pile up
at a
particular characteristic stage
in the cell cycle.
And this was
controlled by these
checkpoints.
These checkpoints are of
enormous
importance because if something
goes wrong with them,
as happens often in
cancer cells,
then you get a huge increase in
instability of the
genome very similar to the way,
losing, for example,
mismatch repair
causes instability of the
genome and therefore things that
can cause a
cell to forget to divide when
it stopped dividing when it hits
its
neighbors, which part of the
cell it belongs to and so on.
Those kinds of changes will
come with much greater
frequency.
Another thing that was
completely remarkable was
because it was yeast
it was relatively easy to find
genes that were broken.
Going back to
complementation,
leaving aside the
technicalities,
if we had a mutant
that's a TS lethal and it's
dead, if we put in a good copy
we'll know it
because the cell won't die at a
high temperature anymore.
So, you can sort of see from
the first principle it was
relatively
straightforward to find the
genes in yeast that are
necessary for cell
cycle control.
The remarkable thing is that
they've been conserved all
the way up to humans that the
proteins that are involved in
the
cell cycle control are
virtually identical in humans.
So, the
system, again,
is probably locked into place
because it works so well.
And once it was working,
then evolution didn't have a
lot of
space.
I won't say it's completely
identical in human cells,
for
example, have a few more
wrinkles that they throw in.
And fundamentally,
you can see evolutionarily that
the system
evolved once.
One thing I just want to
comment on, and here's just
an example of the sort of thing
that can happen if you get a
problem with
pulling chromosomes apart when
they're not ready,
or something
happens that make a break in a
chromosome.
You will get a double
strand break,
and cells don't like that,
and they try and fix it up.
I think in this case,
you can see that chromosome 9
has picked up a
piece of a couple of other
chromosomes.
This piece here came
from chromosome 8 over here,
and this piece here came from
chromosome
22.
And so, this cell now has
things kind of messed up.
And this
particular chromosome's got
parts of two other chromosomes.
And so, you
can start to think about the
consequences of that.
You'll see when you start
segregating chromosomes,
there are
issues.
And also, the junctions
themselves can sometimes do
things
like creating fusion proteins
that have aberrant properties,
for
example, a signaling molecule
that's now locked permanently
into the on
position or something like
that.
Those sorts of things can
happen by
these as well.
So, here's a very abbreviated
form, the principal that
happens, or what happens so
that the chromosomes become
visible
in the microscope.
There is about a couple of
meters of
DNA in every human cell.
So, you can see almost from
first
principles, it almost has to be
packaged in some way to fit in
that
little, tiny area.
And down at the basic level,
the DNA is looped
around a little cluster of
proteins called histones.
And then, as the
cells approach the mitotic
stage, they package these and
higher, and
higher, and higher levels of
packaging so that the
chromosomes
get more and more compact,
and therefore less like
spaghetti, and
less likely to get tangled when
they are pulled apart.
Now, this teaching as part of
the course.
It's in the book.
It's a
little like glycolysis,
though, and there's so much
detail.
It's hard
to notice at all.
And what I've tried to do here
is just sort of
take a step back,
focus you on the really big
parts of the process.
But you can see this is a sort
of typical textbook thing
showing you
the various sub stages of this
process that cytologists have
given
names to each part of this.
For example,
you can see the chromosomes
lining up at the equatorial
phase just before they're going
to be
pulled apart.
One little detail which I
glossed over at this point
as you can see that the
chromosomes are,
of course, surrounded by the
nuclear membrane.
And, at least in many cells,
what
happens is just before the
chromosomes are going to be
pulled
apart, this nuclear membrane in
a matter of 20 or 30 seconds
goes from
being a membrane into sort of
breaking into a whole little
series
of membrane sacs.
And then, after the chromosomes
have pulled apart,
now you reassemble the nuclear
membrane around each set of
chromosomes.
And I think there's still an
awful lot to be learned
about how that particular trick
is done.
And that's a
textbook diagram.
These are the kinds of things
the
cytologists were looking at as
they were describing it.
And one thing
you can certainly see,
I think, is that there are a
lot of, if you want
to think of them as cables,
this whole process is done by
molecular
machinery.
And in fact,
one of the key things for
ensuring that the
chromosomes are all lined up is
each are attached to each
pole of the cell.
So, an individual chromosome
feels
tension on both sides,
and there's pretty good
evidence at this point
that says that what has to
happen before mitosis is allowed
to proceed
is that each duplicated
chromosome must feel the tension
on both sides.
And if one of them is only
attached on one side,
it's not allowed
to go ahead.
Here are a couple more
pictures.
The chromosomes are in blue,
and all this cabling is in
green.
You can
see a molecular machine's
basically at work.
And I wanted to show you
this picture because this is
important.
There's two parts to
this.
Julia, could you hit?
So, this is a normal mitosis.
These are
in lung cells from a newt,
which are very flat.
So it's easy to visualize them.
I believe this is by Nomarski,
a kind
of optics called Nomarksi
optics.
What they're doing,
the duplicated
chromosomes are getting lined
up at the equatorial position in
the cell,
and you get a spindle attached
to one side, and then a spindle
attached to the other.
And once that's happened,
then you can see
the chromosomes.
Watch this one over here,
for example.
It just got
attached, and it's being pulled
into the middle.
And once the cells feel that
all the tension,
there's tension on all of
them, and then it enables the
next stage of the process.
And you will
see each of the daughter
chromatids segregate before.
And, I just want
to impress upon you it's
complicated enough just
replicating the DNA at
the fidelity we talked about.
An awful lot of other stuff
has to go on.
And it would be a reasonable
question: is there ever a
mistake?
And there is.
This one actually
shows another cell where
there's going to be a mistake.
You can't
see it yet, but you can see the
chromosomes are all condensed
up.
And they are beginning to get
these spindles attached.
And as they get
attached to the site then they
get localized in the central
part right
down the equatorial plane of
the cell.
But, I think you'll start to
see the problem emerging at the
moment.
I think it's going to be this
guy right here.
I think a little arrow
will probably appear before too
long.
But what's happened is this
one didn't get properly
connected on both sides.
But, the cell's going
to go ahead anyway.
Watch.
The one up here is going to get
pulled in.
There it goes.
It's getting pulled in.
And then, once it's in there,
then the cell is going to go
ahead and divide anyway.
So you can see
what the problem is.
This one's got two over here,
and
this one over here is missing
it.
This process is known as
non-disjunction.
This is the sort of thing that
happens in cancer
cells that have broken,
where the checkpoint gene is
broken.
And
then, if you have that,
then the cells go on.
The same problem
happens in meiosis,
and it's up here.
It's the same principle that if
you end up with,
if you don't segregate
the cells, the chromosomes
correctly, then you can end up
with
a sex cell that has two copies
of one of them.
And the other one has
none.
And if you have two copies,
or 2N plus 1N,
then you end up with
a trisomy.
And if you have zero plus N,
you end up with what's known
as a monosomy.
So, these would be from defects
in
meiosis.
I'll just close by saying the
one that you probably have heard
of is Down's Syndrome which is
trisomy 21.
That comes about from
this sort of process.
It's a very debilitating
genetic deficiency.
Most of you are probably
familiar with it.
This process happens.
Things go wrong at meiosis,
about one in every fifth
detectable
human pregnancy doesn't go to
completion for the most part
because
of an underlying problem like
this, that the body is set up to
need
the pairs of each chromosome.
If you have one too many or one
too few
it's usually lethal.
So, if one in every five human
pregnancies has
that happened,
you end up with a miscarriage.
My wife and I have
been through it.
It's a devastating experience.
I think you can just look
around and figure the odds.
A significant
number of the people in this
room are going to have to cope
with this.
And I'm just bringing this up
for your attention right now is
it
something that in our society
we tend not to talk about very
much
unless maybe you're a Hollywood
movie star and it makes it into
the
tabloids or something.
But it's a very common human
experience, and
very difficult to cope with.
But there it is,
for most of those
pregnancies that terminate very
early, usually the underlying
cause
is a problem that traces back
to the kind of stuff we see here
where
something went wrong during the
segregation process of making
the
sex cells.
And as I say,
if it happens in just
our ordinary cells,
that's one of the thinks that
leads the
progression to cancer.
OK, so I'll see you on
Wednesday.